all right you guys ready to go to the
beach and go camping you want to see
ponies
yeah
oh just fog out there what are you
eating
[Music]
that cookie so that the sheep says bath
and the cow says Moo but what does the
angry cow say and what does the angry
sheep say what does the angry rooster
say taco doodle doo
pony
well we finally made it we're here at
Assateague and I made a little mistake
so apparently this is a walk-in only
campsite and it's a little bit of a
little bit of a jaunt to our spot which
wouldn't be a problem if I hadn't have
brought all of that oh you got that help
me out
oh good job all right
you all ready go let's go to go to camp
huh
yeah keep going buddy keep going you're
doing it she's going you're heading the
right way be cold Tommy here come on in
but come on go over here put yourself by
the table what are you guys okay a
little bit of a walk
are you watching with you Paul you'll
see the ponies now they're all over
you'll see them deals you'll see him
gonna be uneven but really don't want it
anywhere near that fire you know
okay so for dinner tonight we're having
casado
or beans and rice with some steak in it
then slightly burnt cheesy fries we try
well what is it 9:50 so so we got him to
bed a little early just like we were
planning yeah oh I ate a dad in his
daydreams he gets delusional when he's
stood apart was that the worst night's
sleep ever
or just like top five
and it was because of this one not this
one this one was good he went to bed
very easily he liked this one I now
crown you the new favor love you but
your rankings took a hit
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
is it yummy you like camping tell me
it's raining ah nothing like water and
sand
is it you pick that up
oh there he goes
good job knees this big strong knees
alright man
I'm didn't get up in your car seat oh
well you guys have fun
oh so we went camping with both of the
boys for the first time ever and we were
very naive we thought it was gonna be
just relaxing and chill it was a it was
a lot of hard work but I had a load of
fun didn't you bigger so it was a lot
harder than we thought is a lot more
work than we thought and it went by a
lot quicker than we thought but we had a
great time and I think we're gonna do
this again we're just gonna learn from
our mistakes and plan a little better
and maybe not be as ambitious thanks for
watching and if you liked this video
check out some more other great videos
at the outdoor boys YouTube channel we
put out new videos every week thanks for
watching